i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
welcome to the david pakman show i am
fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman today
and you know what we've got a lot to
talk about so let's just hop right into
it first and foremost let's talk about
the midterms because we do have a very
important day coming up very soon
and that is labor day
and
typically in election years once you hit
that labor day mark everybody
switches into general election mode
so if you're already
tired of midterm news
then i am very sorry because there's
going to be a lot coming out once we hit
labor day in just a couple weeks here
but
right now
and this honestly is super astonishing i
love to see it though
democrats are looking pretty good
right generic ballot polling actually
has them up against republicans in house
races the senate now looks like it's
firmly going to be in democratic control
to the point where we may not even have
to worry about people like joe manchin
or kirsten cinema for the next two years
things are looking pretty darn good
you've got the post row bump
you've got the inflation reduction act
gas prices are coming down inflation
coming down a little still really bad
unemployment numbers look good on paper
but
there is one thing
republicans have going for them right
now
and that of course is donald trump's
post fbi raid
poll bounce
now i use the term raid
not because i'm you know
agreeing it was a raid but because
that's a lot easier than saying the
fbi's execution of the search warrant at
mar-a-lago so please understand when i
use the word raid what i mean is the
lawful execution of the search warrant
down at mar-a-lago
but
his poll numbers have gotten a bounce
from that
and of course ron desantis's poll
numbers have actually gone down
since the fbi went down to mar-a-lago
and
if that republican anger holds
republicans may do better in this year's
midterm elections
or at least that's the prevailing theory
right
we have seen republicans postulate this
cassidy hutchinson of course who was one
of the star witnesses
of the january 6 committee over the
summer came out the day after
and said well you just handed the
midterms to the republicans
i don't agree
because see there's a big difference
what's happening with the democrats
right now
is that
you have anger
over roe versus wade getting overturned
you have anger
at january 6th
you have the lingering threat of
authoritarianism
coming from all of these
republican-controlled states
taking away rights of certain groups of
individuals state by state
all of that
has angered democratic voters
but more importantly it has energized
them
compare that to what's on the other side
oh we're so mad at the fbi right now
cool
you're going to be mad in a week
you're going to be mad in two weeks
and by the way
the funniest part about that
is a lot of that anger already had
subsided i'm not saying all of it did
because you still have you know the
people out there threatening the lives
of fbi agents threatening the lives of
merrick garland and other members of the
doj the magistrate judge reinhardt
but
the anger had already started to subside
by the time we learned that donald trump
likely had classified nuclear documents
down there at mar-a-lago
majority of independents
support the raid majority of democrats
obviously do republicans
only about half right at i think 50
percent
are opposed to the raid
so even if the republicans by virtue of
trump
got a bounce in the polls which trump
did
i don't know that that anger carries
right you've got the front page or cover
story really of newsweek right now
talking about this post-raid bounce is
this enough to push republicans over the
edge uh no
no it isn't not even close
because the more that comes out about it
the worse it looks for donald trump
now i will give trump credit which is
not something i ever do but i will give
him credit last week
for kind of backing the doj into a
corner
by calling for the release of the
affidavit you know let us see all the
evidence you have including the name of
the leaker
so that we can clear all this up with
the public
well whoever was advising him to do that
clearly understood that the doj can't do
that
you know not only
would they put lives unnecessarily at
risk because we've all seen the threats
coming from trump's supporters
but it also could impede the actual
investigation itself
if we release this
you'd get the names of individuals
cooperating you might get the names of
other targets
you might get more information that
could lead to the destruction of
evidence and we cannot do that
in fact the doj actually came out
within the last couple days
and admitted part of the reason we don't
want to release this is actually to
protect
you
donald trump
but the reason i say that that kind of
backed the doj into a corner is because
trump called for the release he knew
they couldn't do it
so once they say no we can't he goes aha
i gotcha i knew all this was phony
otherwise you'd release it and his
supporters including you know plenty of
people in right-wing media
also jumped on that messaging saying
obviously it's fake
and the reason they're jumping on that
messaging
is because they want to get that bounce
back
they want to make sure that those
positive
poll developments that they have seen
since the search of mar-a-lago they want
to make sure that they hold on to the
midterms
so they want to keep talking about it
because they think it's going to help
republicans in november
but in reality
what it's going to do
is it's further going to energize
democrats and it's going to turn
independence away from the republican
party
so they're stuck between a rock and a
hard place right
they want to talk about it because they
think it helps with the republican base
but at the same time the more they talk
about it the more it's going to turn off
independence
neither party in this country
can win elections maybe win some
primaries obviously
but you can't win a general election
if you do not attract those middle of
the road moderate independent voters you
simply cannot the numbers are not there
so the more republicans talk about it
the worse their poll numbers ultimately
are going to get
they may have gotten that little bitty
bounce right now
but it's not a type of anger that is
sustainable
certainly not in a year when trump isn't
even on the ballot
you know if this was 2024 and this
happened and trump was running that
would help all republicans
but he's not on the ballot this year
so i don't know what the republican
strategy here is
but i do know with pretty much certainty
that it definitely is not working for
them
and you know what else
by the way
is not working for republicans
having rick scott senator from my state
down here in florida running the
national republican senatorial committee
now the national republican senatorial
committee the nrsc
is also the fundraising arm
of the senate republicans
and they got a problem right now
the problem is
they all want to know where the heck the
money is gone
because they have raised 173 million
dollars this cycle it's a lot of money
and they got a lot of contentious races
out there that they need to be spending
this money on
there's just one problem
it's almost all gone
rick scott apparently bad with money
still
and i'll expand on that still in just a
moment but
the republican party
in the senate now only has 28 million
dollars cash on hand
like the situation is so bad that last
week
again right as we're heading into
general election mode they announced
they were withdrawing 10 million dollars
worth of ads
in crucial swing states
like pennsylvania
and wisconsin
two seats republicans desperately need
to hold on to
but right now polls are not looking so
good for them
and they had to pull out their ad buys
because they only have 28 million
they're not going to go blow another 10
million you know a third almost of what
they've got left
on two races
so the big question these republicans
want to know right now is rick scott
where is the money
what the heck have you done with a
hundred and what fifty somewhat almost
million dollars where is it bud
so far no answers
but
i think it's important to point out the
fact once again and i'm sure most
everybody knows that but
it seems a little relevant here right
rick scott before he got into politics
was a businessman he was a businessman
that started a health care company
a health care company that later on down
the road would commit the largest to
date medicare fraud in the history of
the united states over a billion
dollars
and the fraud was apparently so bad that
rick scott in his deposition had to
plead the fifth amendment i think
something of what 75 times
i know that's not as much as trump you
know having depleted 440 times in front
of leticia james a couple weeks ago
but 75 times pleading the fifth so you
don't
incriminate yourself into that massive
medicare fraud that's a lot
and so somewhere somewhere along the
lines
somewhere down the road once rick scott
got into politics
governor of florida for eight years now
he's in the senate republicans looked at
him and said hey remember that time
this guy's company oversaw the biggest
medicare fraud in history right clearly
they can't be trusted with money at all
what if we put him in charge of all of
our money
and then wouldn't you know it all their
money disappeared
now before anybody jumps to any
conclusions please understand i am not
in any way
suggesting that rick scott stole this
money you know put that thought out of
your head right now
right
that's probably the safe thing to do we
shouldn't
we shouldn't jump to any conclusions and
by the way we're not if rick scott had
taken you know 140 million dollars from
the republicans 145 i think is the exact
number um they'd know
right there are receipts for these kinds
of things rick scott could not have
taken the money but he is bad with money
okay that's something we can all pretty
much agree on at this point
so why in the heck republicans decided
to put this guy in charge of the money
still blows my mind
what because he's independently wealthy
he's got a net worth of hundreds of
millions of dollars
would you think he was going to fill up
your campaign coffers with his own bank
account heck no
oh because he knows a lot of rich people
you all know a lot of rich people
you didn't need him to be in this
position
and now you've put yourself
in the position of having a guy
that already shouldn't have been trusted
with money i mean pleading the fifth 75
times that that's 75 major red flags
right there
but you still looked at him
and you said you know what
let's give him the purse strings
let's let him be the standard bearer for
the republican party and
just spend our money do whatever we've
raised a lot of it and now
in the final stretch of these midterm
races
republicans are looking and saying oh
god
we're out of money
we got to take a quick break i am fair
and cousins if you want more from me you
can find me on youtube on my two
channels youtube.com the ring of fire
and youtube.com fair and balanced i'm
also on facebook twitter and instagram
at farron balanced
this is the david pakman show i'm fair
and cousins in for david pakman and
we'll be right back
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today
now if you tuned into the program
yesterday you heard producer pat
doing a wonderful job talking about
donald trump going after
mitch mcconnell going after elaine chow
and i don't want to beat a dead horse
here but i do want to take a couple
minutes
and talk about that story one more time
because i do believe
that there's more
that we need to be looking at here
so in case you missed the story
yesterday donald trump over the weekend
came out
um
let me just read it this is what he put
on truth social
why do republican senators allow a
broken down hack politician mitch
mcconnell to openly disparage
hard-working republican candidates for
the united states senate
this is such an affront to honor and to
leadership he should spend more time and
money helping them get elected and less
time helping his crazy wife and family
get rich on china
so of course elaine chao
was donald trump's transportation
secretary and yes there were plenty of
you know allegations against her while
she was transportation secretary that
she was
steering federal money towards her
family business they were going to
investigate that
but then after she resigned after
january 6 the
doj just said ah forget it let bygones
be bygones right um
that's terrible
and of course it was trump's doj but uh
that doesn't mean the doj couldn't still
do that right
i mean there were credible allegations
right there was evidence that suggested
that she was using her position to
benefit her family business
kind of sounds like the thing we ought
to be investigating right isn't that the
kind of thing that we want to root out
of politics
but all of that aside
it's the attack on mitch mcconnell
himself
that really stuck out to me
because trump like everybody else in
this country looks at the poll numbers
and right now those poll numbers show
that not only are democrats most likely
going to retain control of the senate
but they're probably going to pick up a
couple of seats too
they could end up picking up seats in
wisconsin
pennsylvania and ohio
as well as holding on to seats that
they previously thought they may not
including in the state of georgia so
democrats are sitting pretty
republicans
are running out of money
you know thanks to rick scott being a
horrible manager of the national
republican senatorial campaign committee
they're running out of money
they're pulling ads in crucial swing
states including wisconsin and
pennsylvania that i just mentioned
and so they need a fall guy
they need somebody to blame for the fact
that republicans in the senate are doing
very bad
inner mitch mcconnell right
donald trump as we all know has been
going after mitch mcconnell for months
and months and months
just absolutely trashing the guy
earlier this year and last year of
course trying to get people to run
for senate by pledging that they will
not vote for mitch mcconnell to be in a
leadership position again
uh he only got two people by the way to
sign on to that whole deal but
this is something trump has been laying
the groundwork for for a year
replacing mitch mcconnell
so what he is doing right now has less
to do with mcconnell's wife
has nothing to do with the
investigations that should be taking
place
he is setting mcconnell up to take the
fall for the fact
that republicans put forth some bad
candidates
and the irony here of course
is that these candidates
that are likely going to lose
these are all trump-backed candidates
ron johnson in wisconsin latest poll
numbers show him doing terribly right
now well he's also
implicated in the fake elector scheme
but don't worry he said this week he
came out he's like i was only involved
in it for quote seconds
okay
but you were still involved by your own
admission now so
good luck with that in court
then you have of course dr oz in
pennsylvania we all know how that's
going herschel walker in georgia
terrible campaign with a terrible
candidate jd vance up in ohio who trump
thought was going to be the golden boy
can't even beat tim ryan
so all of trump's people are failing
and mitch mcconnell has been coming out
recently blaming trump without having to
name him
for basically saddling the republican
party with these horrible candidates
so trump is trying to flip the script of
course
blame it all on mcconnell because his
leadership is just terrible
so he can finally oust the man that he
has had this personal vendetta against
for over a year
probably not going to work
probably
wouldn't work out well for republicans
anyway even if that happened because
as horrible of a human being as i
believe that mitch mcconnell is
he is good at what he does now what he
does is terrible don't get me wrong
but that guy knows how to play the game
that guy knows how to manipulate people
he knows how to be sneaky conniving
backstabbing all of that
that's how he's gotten so far ahead in
life
so if you remove that guy from the top
of your party you're going to suffer
democrats are going to do so much better
so i guess what i'm saying is
keep up the crusade donald
because i would love nothing more than
to see mitch mcconnell ousted from
leadership
because that's going to create a massive
void within the republican party that i
don't think any of you
know how to fill
and
while we're on the subject of things
trump has done
we obviously have to talk
about all of the investigations against
him
because recently michael cohen donald
trump's former lawyer
fixer
came out in an interview and suggested
that there is going to be quote so much
flipping
on donald trump
once all
of these investigations get to that
point
and of course the big one recently last
week allen weisselberg trump
organization chief financial officer
pleaded guilty to 15 different counts
every count by the way that he was
charged with he pleaded guilty to
they didn't drop any of them so he had
to plead to each and every one of them
and he's only going to get five months
on rikers island he is eligible for
early release after 100 days so he's
going to spend a little over three
months in there
but the judge did warn him last week if
you do not cooperate fully truthfully
and honestly
i can put you away for 10 to 15 years on
rikers which given your age is pretty
much a life sentence
and here's the best part about
weisselberg's
cooperation
with the prosecutors
he can't plead the fifth
he cannot plead the fifth amendment
because he's already pleaded guilty to
all of the crimes he was accused of
a plea of guilty
basically does away with your fifth
amendment rights of self-incrimination
because you've already admitted you did
the things
kind of like the acceptance of a
presidential pardon if you accept a
presidential pardon our supreme court
says you can no longer plead the fifth
because acceptance of a pardon is an
acceptance of guilt
so weisselberg literally has no choice
all right you either go to rikers island
for 15 years which probably would be the
rest of his life
or
you give us every single thing on donald
trump you can't get out of it you can't
excuse it you can't you know call in
sick you can't plead the fifth
you can do nothing
to stop what's coming
and of course that was just one of the
examples of course that michael cohen
recently gave
because that's just one of the many
investigations that donald trump is
facing
we also have the situation in georgia
the fulton county special grand jury
and a lot of donald trump's friends
including his former lawyer rudy
giuliani
have had to testify now
and while we do not know what rudy
giuliani specifically told that special
grand jury
we do know that giuliani is out there in
the media still defending donald trump
still denying all wrongdoing
actually said recently
that he should get his law licenses back
because he hasn't incited a riot in the
last year and a half
but
rudy giuliani is kind of the same
situation
guy is 78 years old
a prison sentence for him especially
given his recent health
is likely a life sentence
even you know five years
with your health conditions
you're probably not walking out of that
jail ever again
so giuliani much like weisselberg has
the incentive
to flip on donald trump
but with rudy i think it's a different
story right i don't know that rudy would
flip
i still don't because i still think rudy
giuliani holds out a slight amount of
hope that trump's going to get back in
office
and then what make him attorney general
i guess he's going to do something great
for me i just know it i just know it he
hasn't paid the bills that i've
submitted to him but he's totally going
to take care of me eventually right
you keep on hoping rudy we'll hope right
there with you right you'll get a good
job in the second trump administration
if it ever materializes but uh
not gonna hold my breath
if you want out of this mess this mess
which by the way all of rudy giuliani's
legal troubles are because he stuck his
neck out for donald trump um if you want
out of that
you're going to have to flip
that's your only option and that's
basically what michael cohen is telling
us all these people whether it's with
the fake elector scheme whether it's
with the new york investigation
whether it's with the other new york
investigation whether it's with the
january 6 investigations whether it's
with the documents investigation down at
mar-a-lago
all of these horrible things that trump
has been implicated in with all of these
walls closing in
somebody somewhere somehow
is going to flip on this guy and once
that first domino falls
the rest of them as michael cohen says
gonna start flipping like crazy
but i will say trump does have one thing
going for him right now
and that one thing of course is the fact
that his poll numbers are looking better
and there was another new poll out this
week that i want to talk about for just
a minute because i think it's worthwhile
because this is exceptionally creepy
following
the fbi's execution of the search
warrant down there at mar-a-lago
what trump calls of course the raid
donald trump's
favorability
among republicans
increased now we know that there's
nothing you know surprising about that
but listen to this
this is according to an nbc news poll as
reported by the hill
republicans who support former president
trump more than they support the gop
climbed to 41
in august
up seven points from may when 34 said
they supported trump more than the party
a slim majority of republicans or 50
percent say they support the party more
than they do trump the poll finds but
that's down from 58 percent
in may
so we went from a 24 point gap
of republicans who said they love the
party more than they love trump
to now a nine-point gap
of republicans who say they love the
party more than they love trump
now think about what that means for just
a moment here
right
these are republican voters so outside
republican world you know
election applications of this poll don't
really exist
this means
that you have 41 percent
of republicans out there based on this
poll
who say that my loyalty is not to a
political party
it's not to the office of the government
it is to donald
j
trump
that guy
that spends all his time golfing and
complaining about things online
that's where my loyalty is
i look at him and i just
um
right i see it i feel it
the power coming off of that man
um that's nuts
and i think it's time we just say things
like that right we just have to come out
every now and then
call it what it is and just say that's
nuts
but that is what today's gop is you know
we we saw it with liz cheney losing by
like 40 points last week we see it
with the way these republicans react
anytime donald trump gets in trouble
you know the individuals showing up and
wanting to attack the fbi a building
filled with people with extensive
firearms training
and they're like oh yeah i'm going to
take them all on yeah it didn't end well
for any of them
but that's how much they love donald
trump that's what they're willing to do
it doesn't matter if it seems crazy to
us to them it seems normal and that's
what we're up against on the other side
and that is why these people are so
dangerous we got to take another break
again i am farren cousins you find me on
youtube at youtube.com
fair and balanced youtube.com slash the
ring of fire twitter facebook and
instagram at fair and balanced this is
the david pakman show and we'll be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman today and if you want more from
me for some reason but you can
definitely get it on my youtube channels
at youtube.com slash the ring of fire
and youtube.com
farron balanced
so this weekend this past weekend mike
lindell ceo of mypillow
held what he had told us earlier in the
week last week was going to be
the event to end all events
he said after this weekend's event you
will not be able to walk away saying
that all of these claims of voter fraud
are a hoax or that any of this is a lie
you will all be convinced he said
that the voter fraud happened because
that is how serious he is about it and
that is how awesome
the evidence that he has
was to be
well it's tuesday
so the event ended on sunday
there was 12 hours on saturday 12 hours
on sunday
and i don't know if you've noticed this
in case you haven't checked
donald trump is not president again
there were not massive reports over the
last 48 hours of amazing evidence of
voter fraud
revealed by the pillow man
in short
mike lindell once again lied to
everybody about everything
and instead according to reports spent
most of his time over the weekend
complaining about the media
whining and crying
about media coverage of him and his
claims
and his multiple now cyber symposiums
he had a couple lawmakers show up
marjorie taylor green showed up and
we'll get more to that in just a few
minutes but uh
yeah
no earth-shattering revelations
no oh my god trump actually won the
election claims from anybody on the left
or the right
he basically paraded a bunch of people
up on stage who said the election was
stolen by
but nobody gave us any evidence
you're watching this
so i'm going to go ahead and assume that
you're not one of the people that thinks
the 2020 election was stolen
congratulations if that does apply to
you because you live in reality i live
in reality
we know that there was no fraud in the
2020 election to the degree that would
have overturned the election results in
any state heck at this point there's not
even enough to overthrow it in any
county any city any election that was
held in 2020 not enough fraud to
overturn any of it
instances here and there absolutely most
of them trump supporters by the way
but no widespread
no irregularities with the voting
machines
no foreign countries hacking in with
their space lasers to change the votes
nothing and mike lindell as i said has
now had three
multi-day cyber symposiums where before
each and every one of them he swore up
and down i'm gonna give it all to you
it's all coming out this weekend here it
comes get ready for it
nothing
not a thing
so mike i gotta ask you bud where is the
evidence
you say you've had it you've literally
now been saying it for over a year that
you're gonna do it and once you do it
it's all over everybody you still don't
even do it
so my question at this point is how can
anyone
even your most die-hard election fraud
believers how can you watch this man
lie to your face for over a year
about presenting you this evidence he
gets up on stage doesn't present you
anything
how can you walk away from that and say
this guy's the real deal he's telling
the truth he's telling it like it is
you're being hoodwinked and honestly i
do still feel sorry for you i know i
probably shouldn't
but he is feeding you lies to sell you
pillows and now coffee
because that's what this is
because on screen
the whole time on lindell tv
or if you were one of the 1500 people
who watched it on youtube or rumble
because that's what they peaked at on
their live stream 1500 they had about
400 people in the audience there
he gave you pillow codes
coupon codes to go use at
mypillow.com.com excuse me or my coffee
yeah that's what you got
because that's what this is
i firmly believe this is all just a
massive con job
now that's not to say that lindell
doesn't believe his own claims i also
believe that he believes it
but i also think that he understands
this is the best possible marketing he
could ever hope for
he still labors under the guise that all
publicity is good publicity no matter
what even bad publicity is good
publicity
he wouldn't be putting coupon codes for
his website
on the screen throughout the whole thing
if he didn't want to use this as a
money-making operation folks
you're being had you're being strung
along by a charlatan
that knows he doesn't have any any
evidence to back up any of his claims
but he can continue to promise you the
world
and they're going to continue to eat it
up
but maybe after this one just maybe
maybe there's enough sane people left
out there who had been following in
following him that maybe they look at it
and they say you know what
i can't
i've been through three cyber symposiums
now and you've given me nothing i have
to move on with my life
i hope that happens
but i doubt it will
one interesting thing though by the way
did happen
at this cyber symposium over the weekend
and it happened when steve bannon and
marjorie taylor green were on stage
because
why not
and it's when steve bannon suggested
that marjorie taylor green
should be the next speaker of the house
of representatives so here he is laying
out his grand plan
for marjory taylor green's future take a
look
and once we win the house
do we have a better speaker of the house
than
mtg look at that
that's amazing
are we going to need her as speaker of
the house to take it to the democrats
[Applause]
all right
let's let's let's remember something
here folks
this is an individual marjorie taylor
green who before being elected
to the house of representatives in 2020
had never held elected office in her
life okay
she is a first-time first-term
politician that hasn't even served a
full term yet
that doesn't even have any committee
assignments and hasn't for over a year
and steve bannon is out there saying she
should be the speaker of the house of
representatives
because nothing matters anymore at this
point
everything is a joke so sure why not
right
now
i'm sure once you get into the house
you're gonna find that most republicans
in there
gonna say no to that and it's not
because they despise marjorie taylor
green but it's because
they've paid their dues
and she hasn't
she is still a freshman representative
that doesn't even serve on any
committees heck even lauren bobert's on
committees
but not green
you have literally no power
you can't even direct money back to your
district
because of your behavior that got you
stripped of those committee assignments
and steve bannon's out here
saying she should be the speaker of the
house
now i know right now that is a
far-fetched idea right folks
four years from now maybe not
i mean matt gates
has hinted
at making jim jordan
the speaker of the house if republicans
take back the house of representatives
they don't want mccarthy they view him
as weak
and if these you know kind of oddballs
your your matt gates's and jordans and
greens and gomer's and those folks
if they all band together
and possibly even expand their numbers
in this year's midterms then yes we
could be looking at a situation where
the worst of the worst
becomes the speaker of the house of
representatives
they've made it clear i mean bannon made
it clear they want the worst people you
could ever imagine
to be up there
and and i don't think he's joking
even mike lindell was like a fighter
true a patriot all that oh yeah she's
great
they love her
the rest of america not so much
so
let's assume for a second republicans
get this you know horrible monkeys paul
type wish
and uh they make her speaker of the
house what happens in two years after
that
i think we would see another blue wave
kind of like we did in 2018
because i think
putting lunacy
on display
putting arrogance instead of
intelligence
on display for the republican party is a
death sentence
and most normal
republicans understand that
you know kevin mccarthy knows
that dan crenshaw knows that i mean it's
so weird that crenshaw is being attacked
as a rhino
you know he's a very extreme republican
but apparently still not extreme enough
to not get attacked as a rhino
we're living in topsy-turvy world here
people i don't understand what is going
on with this republican party all i know
is that if you want to get ahead
you've got to act like the most
ridiculous human being you ever have and
that's kind of why marjorie taylor green
of course showed up at
mike lindell's weekend event
and unfortunately we have even more
marjorie taylor green news this one
actually quite serious
while marjory taylor-green probably
stands no chance of becoming speaker of
the house of representatives and even
though she no longer has any committee
assignments she actually has put forth
legislation right now
and this is legislation
that would ban
gender affirming care
for lgbtq youth here in the united
states
let me read this this is from lgbtq
nation
uh green has introduced a bill that
would make providing gender affirming
care for transgender minors a class c
felony
it would ban federal funds including
medicaid funds from being used for
gender affirming care for transgender
people ban medical schools from teaching
about gender affirming care stop health
care plans under the affordable care act
from funding gender affirming care and
ban anyone found to have performed
gender affirming care from immigrating
to the united states
green's bill lists a number of
procedures that aren't performed on
minors including castration vasectomy
any plastic surgery that feminizes or
masculinizes the facial features and
quote any placement of fat or artificial
implants
in the gluteal region
butt implants
because
marjorie taylor green somehow thinks
that we're
we're out there getting our kids butt
implants
and of course
to make it seem like she's not a bigot
she's not putting any of the criminality
on the transgender folks oh god no no
just the doctors
and if you do any of the things she's
listed in the bill you face 10 to 15
years in a federal prison i'm sorry
minimum of 10 years maximum of 25 not
15. so sorry
this is what they want
this is what they're trying to do
and again
this wasn't just some proposal she's put
forward it's an actual piece of
legislation that she has introduced in
the house a house that of course is not
going to take up this legislation right
now
next year if republicans win who knows
we've already seen by the way some of
the things that she has proposed in this
national legislation happen at the state
level
uh my governor ron desantis this week
came out and said no more medicaid funds
for gender affirming care
this is what they want to do
and marjorie taylor green is laying the
framework for how they will do it
as soon as they get power
listen we got to take another quick
break again i am fair and cousins from
ring of fire sitting in for david pakman
and we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i am farron cousins
from ring of fire i've been sitting in
for david pakman today and hey folks
you know what we really dislike
we dislike socialists here in the united
states
or at least the republicans do right
everybody that is their opponent gets
smeared as a socialist
it's socialism even though most of them
couldn't even tell you what the word
means everything they hate
is a socialist or communist or fascist
even though again they just use those
words interchangeably
because they think that they all mean
the same thing
well now
republican senator marco rubio who is up
for re-election this year his primaries
actually today and he's gonna win
because he's the only one um
he is being smeared by one of his
libertarian opponents
as a socialist
and maybe smear is not the right word
he's being attacked by his libertarian
opponent
as a socialist libertarian opponent by
the name of uh demis dennis excuse me uh
masigoy misagoy
my apologies if i've mispronounced that
but either way mr misagoy
said in a recent interview
that marco rubio
was a socialist
now
marco rubio is many things
but a socialist i i never thought i
would see the day
where somebody would accuse him of being
a socialist but then i read
this article
that was you know an interview with mr
misagoy
he actually makes a good case
and i typically don't say that about
anything that libertarians have to say
but he makes a dang good point
let me read this
rubio is pretty uniquely bad
no argument from me there right off the
bat you got my attention
not just in the sense of being unpopular
and easy to dislike but policy wise this
is a guy who got elected as part of the
tea party wave back in 2010 and when you
listen to him talk about dealing with
issues of economic policy it's all
central economic planning it's not free
markets
i would characterize him by the
republican standards as a socialist
is he a socialist by the means of c is
the means of production to nationalize
everything socialist no
but he's a socialist a socialist by the
obamacare socialist standard i'd say
yeah
okay um
you're losing me a bit there because
obamacare is
in fact not
socialist so gonna have to ding you on
that one mr mizagoy
he continues though
republicans have long presented
themselves as the champions of fiscal
responsibility smaller government and
whatnot i really got turned off to them
in the first part of the 2000s george w
bush was president for eight years for
six of those eight years you had
republican majorities in congress and
what'd they do with the spending and the
growth of government
well
we all know right government grew
spending grew deficits grew all of that
because republicans
are a bunch of
socialists
now i think what mr misagoy was trying
to get at
is that republicans believe in corporate
socialism right
that's what you want
because republicans love to spend money
they love to give money to corporations
we love to prop them up we love to bail
them out we love to give them subsidies
and tax cuts just for the heck of it
so in that regard yes there's lots of
socialism here in the united states most
of it at the hands of the republicans
going directly into the pockets of the
big corporations
so in that regard if of course that's
the point he's trying to make here
if that's what he's calling socialism on
the behalf of marco rubio i agree with
you 100 percent
now there there does come a point
where i disagree with him
not about marco rubio
but
about something else he said in this
energy
because then he gets back you know to
his libertarian leanings he makes a
couple good points he makes a couple
confusing points that make no sense as i
said with the obamacare thing but then
he goes back to his libertarian ways
which
never make any sense here's what he said
we want the market to be as efficient as
it can be because an efficient market
delivers goods and services to people at
the lowest cost possible lowers the cost
of living overall that makes it easier
for people to live and it leaves more
capital left over for people to create
new things that improve people's lives
further
boy i wish i lived in the fantasy world
that you live in mr mizigoy because
literally none of that ever happens ever
and that of course is my big problem
with these libertarians they're living
in a fantasy land
well if we just let corporations do
whatever of course they're going to take
care of people
of course they're going to lower prices
hello what what on earth like what drugs
do you have to be on
to make you have visions of this world
where corporations inherently do the
right thing
they don't
even with government agencies that are
supposed to force them to do the right
thing they still don't do the right
thing
what i would encourage all of these
libertarians in the united states to do
is go get a job at a plaintiff's law
firm and work there for at least a year
see i've worked with a plaintiff's law
firm including actually other law firms
all throughout the country as well
for almost two straight decades
i have seen some of the worst documents
imaginable
from every industry imaginable
whether it's the tobacco industry the
fossil fuel the chemical industry
food companies
they will literally never do the right
thing unless they are forced to pay up
for it
and when that happens they typically
only do the right thing while they think
people are still paying attention then
they go right back to doing horrible
things
so again libertarians i beg you
read some corporate documents
then get back to me
on whether or not you think corporations
will inherently do the right thing
for the american public
and you know what while we're talking
about some of the stupidest things
imaginable that a human being can say
let's talk about herschel walker right
herschel walker
this week
came out
in his opposition to the inflation
reduction act and i'm so sorry it's so
hard to keep a straight face and do this
sometimes
and he said that uh you know
we don't need additional spending on
environmental issues
because aren't there enough trees
already
let me let me read let me read his exact
statement
they continue to try to fool you that
they are helping out but they're not
because a lot of money it's going to
trees don't we have enough trees around
here
climate change solved folks we're done
pack it up environmentalists we've had a
great run but herschel walker just
exposed the whole thing there's there's
already trees out there
they've seen the trees folks what are we
gonna do they know the trees exist
look
look
look okay
i i don't i don't want to be just
exceptionally hard on herschel walker
okay
i know he has had a difficult life
he has openly talked
about you know mental problems that he
has had
and i do not want to pile onto that and
i do not want to you know act like an
ableist here at all
what i will say however with regard to
policy
is that this statement
is unfortunately not an aberration
these are the kinds of things that
conservatives say
to get you to think that any action to
protect the environment to make the
climate
not
hit that point of no return is stupid
right in their eyes we're the stupid
ones because we want to protect the
planet we're the stupid ones
because we don't want to kill 1400
people a year
in the united states alone with air
pollution we're crazy for thinking that
that my god what if we just made things
better for people that makes us
the weirdos
no
somebody who's going out there saying we
got enough trees out here what are we
doing
that's the weirdo
the weirdos are the ones who bring
snowballs onto the floor of the senate
in wintertime and say well climate
change is done
witnessing right now in this country
today look out your dang windows
you see climate change
if you're in texas you're seeing it
firsthand if you're in colorado and
california you're seeing it firsthand
down here in florida we're seeing it
firsthand new orleans seeing it
firsthand
and countless other places all across
the country
a couple more trees here and there isn't
going to solve it and no by the way for
the record we do not have enough trees
out there either
but herschel walker is carrying on in
that long republican tradition of
denying that climate change exists
and then trying to reduce it to its most
ridiculous form
listen that's all the time we have for
today we got a wonderful members only
bonus show coming up for you in just a
little bit but if you want more from me
fair and cousins you can find me
youtube.com slash the ring of fire i'm
also at youtube.com slash farron
balanced and i'm twitter instagram and
facebook at fair and balanced thank you
so much for tuning in this is the david
pakman show we'll see you next time
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below